leave its levy to see here at London
Film on comic-con today have you been
enjoying it I'm so much fun
absolutely so much fun I just AM for
myself I just got my photo taken with
Ludo from labyrinth so that's my day is
made but it's been lovely meeting
everyone seeing everyone walking around
dressed up and seeing some of the other
guests that I'm in amongst them quite oh
my god okay this is Flash Gordon system
hey you think isn't it it is incredible
cuz I've only done once which I purely
Doctor Who before so I mean and but just
as amazing you walk around but
everything so
Doctor Who Laden but we've got predators
and actually yet there's someone done it
was David Bowie from blob and weirdly
and yeah it was the Star Wars guys which
I do enjoy one of your fans as well as
brought you something lovely happily
they did a gorgeous drawing of you you
can show the camera that'd be great
absolutely this is a Molly who follows
me and started the needless this is some
of her work which is quite incredible
she's amazing
excusing in these this is a little
message from some of my other Neve le'ts
so yeah I love it
my my girls I mean such a great
character cause it's such a fantastic
double act as well Jenny what was it
like for you as an actress just great
fun it's um I can pull as many faces as
I want and not feel well that I'm going
over the top or that it's gone too ugly
and people won't be able to deal with it
we get the brilliant lines with stacks
dan is so funny and you get some of the
funniest lines so it's great to sort of
play that sort of the street man to him
and yeah it's just it's just so much fun
can you have and make it as much fun for
the phones
that's works about yeah great
investigating team - exactly
fantastic for the spin-off series come
on Moffitt yeah yeah would you like it's
been our series what kind of thing would
you like to see and do you think it's
likely to happen so now we've seen a web
car step away with you guys yeah I don't
know I mean I would love I would love to
think it would happen or at least if we
got a little special outing for us
because you've got it it's such a
brilliant village group that's sort of
you can do so much in Victorian times
but it's also got that steampunk edge to
it and it can be a bit edgier a bit more
dangerous and because it with the sexual
themes in it as well there's something
that's you know should be should be
talked about more than embrace more so I
think yeah I mean we'd have to see we'd
have to be what what sort of ideas
people can come up with because it's
Victorian and it you've got time travel
all sorts of weird and wonderful stuff I
think it could be well you think about
the freak shows and the Elephant Man
anyway that we have that's real life a
wonderfully freaky the Victorian era was
and then just add us until the mixer you
got it I'm living out I think someone
should definitely do it spin off spin
off definitely now I hope the producers
are watching now I mean we hope it's
gonna spin up obviously but I mean
you've already had some great episodes
on the show how many I mean I mean it's
been part the 50th anniversary year the
shows I mean you've had the Crimson
horror as well the hundredth one as well
I mean that was incredible what was it
like to be part of both of those things
100th episode since like the revival and
also 50th anniversary year I know it's
been it's been really incredible because
I know you realize that what what you've
become a part of and it's it sort of
slowly dawned on us because we just
turned up again for a tiny little
partner good man goes to war just as you
know faster and jenni these characters
plucked out of nowhere and who in and
I'm it's it's just gone amazing for men
in there to be to be involved 100th
episode Crimson horror which was just
one of my actually for the ones that
vast has been n is my favorite because
it was kind of our little story that the
whole vastra crew I lamb and I loved I
loved just that the idea of it it
reminds me of like the old basil
Rathbones Sherlock Holmes that kind of
you know cobbled streets and myths and
stuff like we did with the Christmas
ones as well but it's just yes it's
amazing I can't you know sometimes you
know you got to pinch yourself and look
them we go outside again but yeah I like
what suppose didn't like working with
Matt as well he's sadly leaving now
isn't he I am gonna miss him so much
it's weird cuz he's just become human
but we weren't we went up one night and
he just gave me a massive hug and just
went leave your part of the family you
know I don't feel as weird he's gonna be
leaving and we're still gonna be sorta
left behind a bit but he's fantastic and
he's one of the loveliest men he's just
gonna
he needs to move on and do something
else he sees young and energetic and got
that gun for them so he's got to yet go
and you have already worked with the
next doctor before not in Doctor Who but
Peter Capaldi bird in the sky with irony
yeah we did well oldest we do we've done
a couple of things the first one my
first ever jobs has a thing called
cycles and which was all about a
Scottish mental hospital and and he
plays one of the inmates that I had to
to to interview really early on so yeah
I've known him for a little while and
actually one of the last times that I
saw him was filming a tiger in the
street and John McKee and I were sort of
standing chatting and there's just this
beards walking beard came in between its
he's gone all right
what are you doing Peter he hadn't been
working much the biggest beard ever
beard on a stick to sports so I can't
wait I know I think I know I think I can
confirm I'm gonna be in it fantastic
answer isn't he as well I mean you
looking forward to seeing him in the
show and would you like vastra and Jenny
and Strax to all come back together and
have some shows with him as well yeah I
think Moffitt's already said that we're
definitely going to be in this next
series
I know a key it was out on the tinder
web so as as far as I can tell
official unless he changes his mind but
I'm yeah so I can't wait I think he's
gonna be fantastic he's such a good
actor and such a nice man and I can't
wait it's out besides not to be working
with Matt again and to see him go but
I'm really looking forward to Peter
taking over and seeing what he does with
that I know
he's good as that gets that crazy
excitement oh god you don't know what
someone's going to bring to the next you
know the next regeneration the next step
Doctor Who so I thought wait
fighting times is knowing what would you
like to see happen with your guys
ambassador and Jenny and Strax the next
one Oh God
yeah just more warm oh yeah helping out
the doctor more and well it depends
depends I mean I would love to someone
asked me you know who what would be the
my ideal body to go up against and I
have to see Daleks I've never hired to
work with Daleks yet and I would love to
work with Alex there's a few things that
you would want or maybe the Cybermen but
no Daleks for me they were my favorite
and finally you have work with David
Tennant before as well haven't you lots
of doctors but not again on Doctor Who
what was that like that was amazing
because everyone cuz he'd already done
Doctor Who by the time we did single
father and so the laws of people were
just like oh my god you've got to hug
David tenet and I'm like oh yes I did
yeah
like jealous jealous no lovely another
lovely man just journalist and I get one
of those dogs you kind of you know you
were she had had more to do with them
but you know just I loved her loves I
loved actually playing sort of you know
uptight neppy Scottish woman who's who's
just like God Almighty is just that hot
again you know there's no he was so much
fun great to hear never it's been
absolutely lovely talking to you you
cannot wait to see you back in Doctor
Who and lots of other things you up to
sure as well
you